étienne lapointe se trouver un nouvel
appartement qui lui convient mieux
il sait qu'un déménagement équivaut
souvent à une hausse de loyer pour le
locataire qui suivra on est conscients
des enjeux
en effet dans la dernière année
le loyer moyen de l'ensemble des
appartements locatifs de la région
métropolitaine de montréal a augmenté de
6% la plus forte hausse depuis près de
30 ans à montréal
c'est vraiment ce que je pense qu'on est
en train de perdre la bataille bordas
c'est normal que les loyers augmentent
de 5 6% par année alors que l'inflation
et aux taux de 1 2% est quelque chose
qui fonctionne pas étienne opte donc
pour une cession de bail qui permet un
candidat qu'ils sélectionnent de
reprendre son bail aux mêmes conditions
et surtout au même prix de loyer mais il
rencontre rapidement de la résistance de
la part de sa gestionnaire d'immeubles
c'est quand même une fin de non recevoir
c'était plutôt catégorique de son côté
on a fait pour se désoler
après une première tentative d'envoi par
lettre recommandée infructueuses etienne
décide d'avoir recours à un huissier
pour s'assurer que la vie de cession de
bail est bien reçue c'est sûr que c'est
un peu stressant tout ce processus là
j'aurais préféré que ça se passe plus
facilement etienne a finalement reçu
après notre première rencontre une
lettre de sa gestionnaire d'immeubles
évoquant notamment des réparations
majeures à faire dans l'édifice pour
refuser la demande détiennent on lui
offre trois mois de loyer pour qu'ils
optent plutôt pour la résiliation de son
bail
il faut que la khadra sache que la
cession de bail c'est un droit qui leur
appartient et à moins d'un match sérieux
comme l'insolvabilité de la personne ou
des mauvaises antécédents la personne à
qui on veut céder le bail ça ne peut pas
être etienne n'est pas le seul à vouloir
faire une cession de bail présentement
ce militant pour le droit des locataires
observe un engouement pour cette
pratique
il ya beaucoup de locataires qui
s'intéressent à ce moyen là pour trouver
des logements pour lutter contre
l'érosion loyer abusives
claudia le duke jarre des groupes
facebook comme je t'ai scène mumbai de
plus en plus populaire on voit
l'efficacité de ces gros plan ce moment
qu'on reprenne notre pouvoir en tant que
locataire parce qu'on en a est un des
plus importants qu'on a c'est de pouvoir
faire une cession de bail mais de son
côté le porte parole de la corporation
des propriétaires immobiliers du québec
dénonce ce mouvement qu'il qualifie de
syndicalisme locataires
les propriétaires doivent selon lui
avoir la liberté d'augmenter les loyers
au prix du marché
la loi change que ce soit politiquement
ou via un recours judiciaire parce que
du pack septembre le qatar puisse forcer
un propriétaire peut très bien être prêt
à le libérer
etienne est bien décidé à aller de
l'avant avec sa cession bail
malgré les obstacles j'ai pris rendez
vous au tribunal du logement pour
poursuivre la cession de bail parce que
c'est quelque chose d'important puis je
veux continuer ce combat là ici fait des
bussières mais nicole radio canada
montréal